I'll take a look I see some very mild
active acne and I see some old acne
scars yeah so you probably were on
acutane at some point hopefully because
I'm seeing a lot of scars so I'm
guessing that you probably are on a A
retinoid or retinol maybe a few times a
week and an exfoliating cleanser and
then an SPF for the daytime yeah I mean
you're pretty close I was on Accutane in
college I had hor skin since then I've
probably done two or three rounds of
micro needling a couple rounds of laser
and then I want to do RF at some point
if I could so now I'm just using like C
cleanser cve moisturizer SPF the thing
is your skin is beautiful now it's
nothing to be insecure about I would
have enough